everyone so this is me in a garden on
the weekend reading a book right so very
chill and here's the cognitive channel
between the book and my brain as you can
see there's a clear bandwidth and this
is where the bandwidth between the
cognitive load and the brain is at its
highest so here's someone on the train
that I took a photograph of without
permission so he's looking at his phone
and while looking at his phone he might
have been inspired to catch a new Star
Wars movie that's coming out soon right
so you might want to do it on a weekend
on a specific date that the movie is
launching so then he goes about setting
a reminder because you would want to do
it right then and he doesn't want to
remember the launch deal so this is how
the community channel looks like on your
left is the screen on the phone and on
your right is the brain right in the
train the cognitive resistances and
friction is higher and therefore the
bandwidth is lower right so there are
the noises and the distraction right so
while thinking about the next Star Wars
movie he might have recollected his
experience with the previous novels
movie and the cycle goes on right and
then you know there might be remembering
one of the characters in it and you know
on and on so sometimes this resistance
may cause partial absorption of the
cognitive load or even worse total loss
of intention so comparing this situation
and the situation of myself reading the
book right you'll find that this is
actually a stressful situation France is
introduced subconsciously into that act
itself so in our lives there are many of
these subconsciously stressful
situations that can be avoided
electronically setting reminder is just
one of the example so expenses claim
online bills etc alright so I said about
thinking could there be a better way of
interacting with computers where we get
to a point where we can be continuously
and lightened rather than continuously
torturing ourselves with this repetitive
cha computers can be the bicycle of our
mind pouring from steve jobs so I said
about delegating a lot of my chores into
a note process die named Joe dot so Joe
dot is a NPM package that you can
install and it helps you absorb
repetitive electronic duties so the
first thing that we need to know is when
dealing with Joe da is to have a list of
these duties so I thought it would be
nice to have it centralized so that we
know that we know the number of duties
that do not is handling it's much
clearer that way right so I said about
doing this and I chose JSON as the as
the definition structure for this and I
use I use this package called histories
on which is which allows me to get
comments into in within the text
definition itself so the comments are
very helpful as you can see otherwise it
seems
it machine is right so once you have
that least I said about constructing the
duties itself so the first duty that
Jojo has to do for me as something that
i delegated to is to tell me that it's a
life because I wouldn't want process
that you know i delegate duties to to to
die off and i don't know you and my
bills doesn't get paid or my you know my
my electronic choice doesn't get done
right so the first base case is to tell
it to tell me that I'm a life that he's
a life dude I mean it is a life so okay
so any duties can be packaged as and
shared publicly on NPM or it could be
ran locally as with a local install flag
set to true so what does is it gets the
least that we saw previously it runs
through it and for each item in the
array it actually installs the package
from NPM via the NPM I package that's
also from the song also for mpm so once
its installed the duty it actually Fox a
duty process as a child process and it
starts sending duty calls to the trial
process duty so this duty call can be
scheduled with this definition here it's
a crown expression or a duty can be
called from another duty this is useful
I will see very soon so duties can have
parameters as well right so within this
Duty definition I've included five
parameters to a duty cocktail and mill
so this Duty is essentially about
killing that lock file so this closes
the loop of Judah telling me is alive
but it's actually logging it too
Oh a lot far right so but now I need it
to actually tell me and the interface
between me and Jo dot can be you know a
meal a meal from Joe dot so what we have
here is till this lock file look out for
this string and if you find it you know
send it to me email so this is the
implementation of the duty so the idea
is that all of these duties can be
assembled with NPM packages and NPM as
we know it has so many features and
functionalities right so these features
and functionalities as time Sanjay was
saying later earlier are very capable
you know we could use nightmare we could
use all sorts of here I used till you
know to do all of these electronic
charts and you don't have to be it
doesn't have to be very complex you just
need to know how to string together a
couple of NPM packages facet some
parameters and that's it so these are
some of the ideas that I'm currently
working on bashful file adding prices
downloading remembering nuggets of
information commit doing something when
I commit easier way to do revolve and
check links on my webpage for you know
things that are links are no longer
valid so these are some of the duties
that if I do not delegate to Georgia I
have to do and it's again it's a
repetitive torture because it doesn't
seems like a creative thing that I want
to deal with on my computer so these are
simple duties so I thought there might
be an opportunity to add slightly more
complex duties that make Joe doubt more
useful so we could add a duty that gives
me a volt power interface like this that
deals with do this so it's like a mating
so I could use a head of bots that deals
with doodle as well so there are areas
there are automation tools like grant
and God that's similar in
in terms of automation right it does
automation as well right on there is
another room for something like judo too
because the domain is personal
automation also there is another tool
called p.m. to that does process
handling but it doesn't do the ecosystem
of duties that we can actually create so
there are few more areas that car is
currently i'm currently looking at
making duties easier to create share
fine install and configure so the
written up a some documentation here if
you want to check it out the current
state is available everything is wave on
github and that's it life can be better
with javascript thank you
you